this is a production of Cornell
University I am a fifth year now and I
came here straight out of my undergrad
which I did at University of Connecticut
I'm Katie and went to the University of
Florida and I did a bunch of different
volunteering slash field tech gigs and
basically what I was taking three years
off by like doing work and my name is
Kara I'm a first year PhD student in the
entomology department I went to Yale as
an undergrad and did various summer
research projects through fellowships
that I got through the college and then
I went on to a master's of Public Health
there afterwards and then I took a year
off of academia and worked on ranches in
Wyoming and Argentina
and during that time and research in
humans very good so we research hi my
name is Angie I'm not a eunuch from
Columbia and I did I have like a long I
didn't
undergrad time I have two we are
required to have a cat we search for her
then
like present PCs then my work in
Institute as I was Research Institute in
Colombia till then I did my masters in
the University of Puerto Rico my the
West and then I work as a manager Nick
University so what we're gonna do today
is in these different sections of the CV
and one thing what we want to emphasize
that there's no real hard and fast rules
to writing a CV but these are some ways
that you can organize it that I think a
lot of people career and start off with
just your education section which is
pretty simple but should include just
wearing your undergraduate what your
major was and it's also nice some
institutions really and requirement and
some a lot of programs really but that's
kind of a kind of institution by
institution thing and then the next next
section which some people have some
people don't but it's kind of nice to
orient what you're interested in is this
kind of research section and so that's
actually a really short summary of what
you're interested sometimes it can even
be just keywords kind of topics that you
really kind of your kind of but anyway
that's a very short section is
definitely optional
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't want to make it a very long
you don't want to publications and
presentations so depending on how many
you have they cancel different sections
for me mine still just once sections
both together so for publications you
can include any peer reviewed or
published publications it can also
include PCs if they are like archived
and online three years University
institution and sometimes they are kind
of readily accessible like somebody can
search it and find it online and read it
you can put it in the publication
section for presentations I would be any
symposiums or conferences you've got to
either it's just a great institution and
posters and oral presentations both
count and then of course when you
actually put them on your CV make sure
you're following citation guidelines and
you keep it consistent so pick one and
then stick with it be the whole way
through
yes so she asked how you cite for a
poster or presentation and the way that
I've done it is that I put the title of
the poster of presentation
what conference it was and then where
the conference was and also the date yes
and many other questions to see if you
guys know we're going to be repeating
the questions back to you for the sake
of recording yes good question so she
asked how far back you should go in
terms of putting publications on your CV
that is a good question and it's I think
it's going to depend on the person so if
you have a lot of publications you might
not want to put the ones from no 2007
that aren't necessarily relevant or what
you want to do moving forward but like
if you don't have you have like two or
three I would say it depends on what the
CD is for like a lot of the grad school
ask for a two-page CV so it's moving
like a resume so then you'd have to kind
of narrow it down to fit it on then you
might just want to select the most
relevant one so type of research you're
applying to but if it's a true CV then
it's really everything you've ever done
yeah so I'd like more and more concise
over the years and I think so you might
list the title if it's basically the
same across conferences you change a
couple of words but it's still
essentially the same poster pick a title
and then list the locations and the ears
so for me I usually keep a copy of my
full resume that that it will be very
helpful and then when you're applying to
decision you like make it concise and
very specific to the position of your
body so that that's really helpful like
keep a copy in your computer with
everything that you have done so I I
find that there's like a lot of
variation between schools what do you
ask in terms of resumes or CDs I I think
a lot of the work that is started the
very beginning when you emailed the
professor to start a contact that you
need to basically show as much as you
don't I'm whatever it is relevant for
this professor is when you wanted to
highlight so you can have like their
resume with everything that you have
done and a disco in pace
some produced partial ratification but
or to highlight but it's when you want
to choke that professor you are
contacting that moment so if there's a
little variation but if you have like a
long research experience
it's better to show like that experience
you don't need to put every poster every
talk you just want to go maybe the most
prestigious conference that you had gone
and you can estar sometimes people like
to see the history which is started in
the desert 10 years ago that's pretty
good something like that so you want to
emphasize that you have been consistent
in a long history of doing research and
you can highlight just maybe the most
prestigious so they want I think have
most of the daily they are something
like no other questions ok so next I'm
going to be talking about two more
sections you can experience and
volunteer and extracurricular so I were
just for context these are important to
grad schools first of all on a common
way if funding students is through to be
a chips so if you can show that you've
got some sort of experience you're still
on teaching then that maybe looks an
application process so she's been an
undergraduate ta that's definitely
something you're gonna want to put into
your CV for your application or if
you've done any sort of tutoring whether
it's a college level or even if you
tutored younger children that shows that
you have experience teaching someone and
can explain concepts in a way that's
understandable to others and then curl
your volunteer an extracurricular
experience one important thing is to
highlight any leadership role as her
managerial role as you pass so even if
you've been in the club for all four
years
you've just been president this past
year something you're gonna want to put
that like upfront in your description of
that topic so maybe like highlighting
your president role in the title or
something like that you're just and
beside those who whoever's looking at it
you know that you have this experience
leading others and you're gonna want to
be selective and succinct I'm speaking
with some of you guys it sounds like
you've done like a million and one
things and that's amazing but you aren't
going to have all that room for a
two-page CD so you're gonna want to
choose what's most relevant or what you
feel most passionate about you expect
the most time on um if you're feeling
like you're pressed for space better
tech to elaborate on the things that you
care about I've done a little bit more
with then it was something II did it
maybe one day one year and yeah so you
can use this to support other sections
of your of your resume but you don't
want to be redundant so for example if
you volunteered in a lab you're gonna
want to put that under research
experience it's not only pollen to your
experience first of all he is writing
care more about your research experience
so that's probably where I was gonna go
first
did you have that experience even if
it's volunteer or not okay you're gonna
want to put that under research
experience to highlight it more
effectively and then don't repeat it in
the volunteer obsession and yeah so I
mean I guess it is important if you have
done any volunteer extracurricular
experience to add that in because just
like your applications for undergrad
grad schools Karen and you're gonna add
something to the community a more
vibrant place so like for example all
the students here working on this it's
because of people who care our active
and engaged community so if you can show
you're gonna be that type of person when
you come to school then that's gonna add
something to the grad and grad schools
are gonna want you more for that type of
personality trait
so say you're helping someone learn
English yes I would definitely I I think
first of all you're teaching second of
all that shows that you're engaged in
the community and care about others and
I think that's something for Jeff yes so
the question is if you have some sort of
qualification for the past and then
didn't necessarily follow up on that
it's not actually a negative thing to
put in because it shows that you weren't
committed to it um I think that would
depend on on the situation but I would
say I would still include it because you
have that qualification and that
training and so it could come in handy
I think especially if you at some point
in your application can explain why you
didn't pursue that and that it's not
because you hate teaching people or
something and I would make it clear why
you get away from that but I think it'll
depend on like the context remember this
is this is all complimentary with the
rest of the package don't think that
this is my unique professors you are
flying to a lab or to a department and
there's going to be a professor they say
his sister looks interesting and that
person is going to read your CV and you
SOP and detail because it's a commitment
it's because in both weight so it's
going to read everything and you don't
want to be redundant and then you can
say yeah I have this experience and then
you enjoy
it's a bead you can say yeah I have
things like my coal was go it's
complimentary you put your the CV
highlights basically two skills what you
are done and then you Nestle feed you
basically invalidation but it's nice
words about the experience and decisions
of life things like that also doing
about the question about something
that's maybe seems slightly irrelevant
to what you're applying for I think also
you can find surprising or unexpected
connections with the person you're
applying to
by adding things that aren't necessarily
about science like for example I added
in my work with horses on ranches in my
application to grad school and the P I
that I worked with now that's worth of
courses for life so it's actually
something we talked about during her
interview and so I I didn't just ignore
that part of my interest in my life
because it didn't have anything to do
with mosquitoes so yeah I think you
weigh what's important and what you have
space work that's right alright a tricky
section just because terminology can
vary so probably a lot of you have
received some kind of a scholarship or
fellowship or financial aid in college
so you want to be careful that first of
all the things that you're putting on
your CV in a great fashion in a word
section you differentiate according to
the type of for it is I'm so fellowships
are generally it's some sort of program
where you your status is as a felon
so usually like the words will be in the
program name but it may or may not
include financial aid or a stipend
usually it's a fellowship that's
associated with research usually when
people see fellowship they think
research fellowship scholarships can be
other sorts of financial aid or you may
have received the scholarship that's not
research or maybe you just didn't have a
title of fellow it was a part of a
program but you
applied for it and got it generally Oh
maybe the others can speak to this to
you but I would sleep with either
scholarships or research grants as
descriptions because that's kind of what
the eyes are used to reading the
scholarships is something that's like
it's a turn the optics of the
undergraduate level but not as much as
the graphical address so if you
specifically got money for research we
can call it a research grant you're part
of a fellowship program you should pull
your scholarship program and generally
if you got any meat based scholarships
that's not something that goes on your
CV just because it's you know need-based
and it's not something that you applied
for giving your experience um and you
want to clarify especially the best
thing that you can put in this in this
section is that you applied for money
for your own independent research which
is probably what you're going to put in
there and you know that's something that
if you haven't done already like it's a
really great thing to ask your senior
year but yeah so like the general idea
with this section is to say funding for
my research and I got some even if it's
just a couple hundred dollars like the
amounts at this stage really doesn't
matter as much as you apply but yeah and
works on an application with someone in
your lab either the kiai of the lab or
the post postdoc in the lab or HD
student you can state that either a CV
that you apply it with X Y Z yeah so Y
is a more general statement so in it it
can definitely capture those things if
you've gotten multiple travel awards I
might put that in a different section
but that's definitely something that can
go in you would just want to state
clearly that that you received to travel
over to attend just conference and
that's a really good thing so the
question is about if you get two awards
and you can only choose one which is
wrong you can just say this needs a word
X&Y for conference flank I don't think
you need to say that I only use this one
that's that's like a general point to
make if you have fights for something
and you received it or even if he
received an honorable mention for
something this is something that comes
up a lot like you know minorities and
women tend to say less often when
they've received an honorable mention
but that matters it shows that you
worked for it and that you were almost
there near a high quality candidates so
it's something like that as sort of like
borderline but it shows that you did the
work and that you were you know either
got accepted or an honorable mention
included especially for research
question so it's about if you're
acknowledged know
did you help develop I feel like that's
something if you're developing materials
for any kind of course even if you're
like not an official author on anything
that's something that should probably go
to your teaching section it doesn't have
to be like author manual XYZ but it can
be just a description of what you did so
developed materials for manuals you know
named just like brief words they like
and capture the you know the content
yeah yeah if you have a citation for the
manual that's awesome you know if not it
can be just sort of a description of
your own it's nice when you can sort of
plug in a way that's like author or like
co-author or editor or something because
that's just like it like helps people
key in on it but if it's not that simple
then just trying to state what you did
it in concise way it's the great you
know alternate it I just want to quickly
go back to the second half of a previous
question I'm at this weekend
does the camp put it on the CV and you
can apply for it and you guys are not
accepted so you put it on your CV under
yeah okay so for the skill sections of
birds or your CV you should be very
specific and concise you should
experience that you have had in previous
jobs undergraduate research or film or
lab courses it will be great if you can
be as specific about specific about the
the type of position that you apply in
for example if you're applying for a
molecular lab that require molecular
techniques you should like
you should add that you know how to do a
PCR and you know how to do Westar blood
I do that you also looking at if you
know any type of programming language
like C C++ or Java if you know any if
you are proficient in another language
like Mandarin Spanish or French that's a
great skill to have if you are very
proficient in working with a computer
software like R or barrel that's a great
skill to taught you to skill Saoirse on
your CV and not so great to add in this
in the skill section and personal
attributes like responsible teamwork and
Microsoft form a kinship or Macintosh
software proficiency and that's
something that you would like to take
care of you okay so we'll probably
discuss this a lot as we're going
through your CDs with you but these are
just a few things about formatting and
by the way we're going to post all these
powerpoints online so don't feel it
needs a you know type furiously but
generally you know just really simple
the first bullet is just about contact
information so you want to have like
your name pretty clear on the first page
nothing super fancy but clear and your
basic contacts email and phone number
and mailing address european cds tend to
like add a lot of personal information
but like you know even like if you're
married or like a photo for american CDs
you keep it simple it's basically how to
contact me and you want your full name
on the rest of the pages and so you want
to make sure all of your dates are
aligned to the right or to the left not
just kind of somewhere in the middle so
that they're easy to see and so people
can track your experience over time and
you want to just generally keep your
formatting really clean and simple and
you
want to try to cram things in it's
always better to be concise and
selective than to make it denser because
your pies would be reading a ton of cv
so they want to be able to find things
really easily and you want to keep your
font somewhere between 11 and 13 points
so fun fact I printed all your CDs so I
know that like there are some that we're
like really big or like really small and
so one good trick is like hand it to
someone tell them to like hold it right
here and then see if they squint or see
if they move the paper away so you want
it at a comfortable reading distance and
you want to use caps and bold to
emphasize headers or subsections I've
been guilty of overuse of italics in the
past but it tends to make things less
readable not more readable and this all
relates to just make sure you print it
before you send it because that'll
really help you catch things that are
outside of the principle area
most people want things within one inch
margins on all sides and it'll just help
you catch typos and stuff so if you have
access to a printer definitely do at
least one final print before you're
emailing it out to a PI that you're
really interested in or submitting it to
a grad school application and one quick
fix for a lot of Microsoft Word issues
is to save it as a PDF then print it and
then any formatting thing problems might
come up so just a quick summary of what
we've been talking to you about we want
you to align your experiences and skills
the lab that you're applying to as we've
sort of mentioned there's a couple
different stages at which you might
submit your CV either in an email to a
PI where you're describing what you're
interested in and asking if they're
accepting applicants of graduate school
or if their department is it can vary a
lot by institution then there's the
stage at which you submit it online
through the department in a more formal
process so you want to make sure that
you're tailoring your CV the length of
it and
what you're saying in it so what who
you're sending it to and when you want
to identify your strengths don't bury
them it's like really easy to do that
so really emphasize them on your CV and
make sure they stick out and focus on
clarity and ultimately the best thing
that you can do is do more research look
for more research opportunities apply
for grants for doing research and things
like that about the two pages the more
concise is the better and more clear for
people but I will not kill myself is
like 22.5 yeah when I apply to schools
my CV had like four page but you know
I've been like in a long journey before
HD so I would not kill myself but I I
know I will probably remove some of the
stuff I put there for application and at
this moment when I look back but I don't
kill yourself is like I have like a
little longer or is like one page it's
okay yeah if it's less than two pages
also don't worry like that's fine and
especially like it depends on what point
you're at and where you're where you are
in your academic career so these are
just a few resources will email this out
to you guys so but these are generally
like places where you can find out more
about science careers and about how to
you know sell yourself as a scientist
and just little things like that this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu